hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book nineteen of the City of God st.
Augustine is going to discuss the
virtues and he's taking as he does so
often in his work some of the
perspectives and viewpoints of certain
of his pagan predecessors and he's
placing them into a larger Christian
theological and thereby also
metaphysical framework in this case
we're dealing with the issue of what is
the supreme good for human beings what
does genuine happiness consists in so
we're also dealing with what we could
call at issue in moral philosophy and
although Augustine thinks that the
virtues are indeed extremely important
and we should cultivate the virtues
they're not enough they don't get us to
happiness itself
they don't comprise happiness and when
he's saying this he is specifically
targeting as he's going to in the work
one school of philosophy the Stoics who
had held that virtue and happiness and
living in accordance with nature are
pretty much all the same thing now one
can quibble about that but we're going
to put that aside for the moment because
that was a common read of the Stoics
both in Augustine's time and in the time
of the Stoics and much later the idea
was that simply by possessing the
virtues to the full extent that one
could and what virtues do they mean that
what we call the four cardinal virtues
temperance prudence or practical wisdom
justice and courage or fortitude by
possessing these a human being would
thereby be enabled to be happy as happy
as a human being can be in this life
that is superlatively happy superlative
li you diamond in the greek right and
augustine is going to contest this now
again I want to point out that he's
denigrating the virtues he's not saying
that they don't matter he does say
virtue in fact has the highest place
among human goods so it's better than
pleasure it's better than freedom from
pain it's better from the first
principles or things or impulses of
nature it's better than authority it's
better than riches it's better than all
these other goods insofar as he's saying
that he is in agreement with the
Aristotelian and the Plata NIST's and
the Stoics with with so many other
schools of philosophy so then how is he
different
well Augustine thinks that the highest
the supreme good for us human beings
doesn't lie in virtue but it's something
that we attain to through virtue and
it's something that lies outside of this
earthly human existence although it also
pervades that existence and guides us
within it
what is that supreme good well you can
call it God you can call it blessedness
with God you can call it eternal life
you can also call it eternal peace all
of these are you know connected with
each other and the idea is that by
developing the virtues and living in
accordance with them developing what
Augustine and other points is going to
call moral rectitude or rightness we
then are enabled to have this
relationship with God that exceeds the
visible temporal existence that we're in
right now the world and we become part
of a larger Commonwealth or City the
City of God which includes the Blessed
in heaven who truly enjoy happiness
so the virtues aren't nothing but
they're not entirely the best so they're
not the supreme good itself and one of
the arguments that Augustine makes in
this section that we're going to unpack
now a little bit more is that the
virtues in this earth
existence for us have to wage war upon
the vices and they don't wage war on the
vices merely in an external way so that
I is the virtuous individual have to
fight against the vices that are gonna
come and get me or the vices of other
people Augustine says well there is some
of that but even more important is the
fact that my virtues are fighting a war
with the vices within me I am the
battleground I am the one who has to
choose to be virtuous over and over and
over again when certain parts of myself
would rather be vicious would rather be
the opposite of the vices and he he goes
through each of the cardinal virtues
some in at greater length than others
and examines this so let's take
temperance to begin with in Greek so fro
Sunni as he brings up right
Augustine brings up this famous passage
from st. Paul that says that the flesh
lusts against the spirit and what do we
mean by that we mean that our body our
bodily flesh wants us to do things that
the spirit or the mind or whatever is
higher would say no no that's too much
so when it comes for example to drinking
and eating or engaging in intoxicants
right or sexual desire or even just like
laying around and soaking up the
sunlight or staying under the covers
when it's nice and warm under them and
cold outside any of these sorts of
things we have a tendency to allow what
he's calling the flesh and Greek Sark's
right the to to go against the spirit
and he says that these two are contrary
to one the other so you can't do the two
things that you would and if we want to
attain the higher good we have to
subordinate our flesh our bodies our
desires and there
their lust for pleasure we have to
subordinate that to something higher
which is the spirit and the spirit is
what allows us to participate in a you
know existence with the divine so we're
in this perpetual battle at least if you
don't want to call it a war of trying to
make sure that we're not doing the wrong
things with our bodies because we do in
fact desire to do those those things so
even if we are temperate we're still
struggling he goes on and he says well
what about prudence or if you want to
translate it another way practical
wisdom this is a very important virtue
in fact within the Platonic and stoic
traditions this is really the virtue
that governs the others even in the
Aristotelian tradition you cannot be
fully virtuous in the sense of having
the other virtues developed without
exercising prudence and Augustine says
prudence is really good however if you
think about the function of prudence in
this lifetime it's constantly occupied
it has to exercise vigilance as he says
it has to be on guard by discerning by
distinguishing good from evil because we
need to pursue the good and we need to
avoid or prevent or eliminate the evil
and we can't do that unless we actually
have prudence because there are so many
times where we are likely to mix those
two up now why in fact do we need to
distinguish between good and evil well
because we're screwed up and we are
likely to have have problems in figuring
this out he says we want to avoid any
mistakes about what we should have
desire and what we should avoid prudence
teaches us it's an evil to consent to
sin it's a good to refuse this consent
but this evil isn't removed by
temperance or prudence
just helps us out and he says what about
justice the virtue that allows us to
give each person what they are owed what
is their due
what we ought to give them well justice
is great it's not that we shouldn't have
justice but let's not deceive ourselves
about just what justice can accomplish
he says that it's working towards the
end of proper order and we'll talk about
that proper order in just a second it's
not resting in it
even if we are just we're still having
to make sure that we actually do the
right thing
situation a situation my having made a
choice to do the right thing a week ago
does not actually make me do the right
thing right now I have to continually
exercise that virtue of justice against
my own tendencies to be unjust and what
is the proper ordering Augustine says
that God is above and then this spirit
and the flesh the the flesh should be
subordinated to the spirit and the
spirit should be subordinated to God and
without that proper ordering we don't
have justice this is not something that
you can snap your fingers and have done
once and for all there's no pill to take
even divine grace flowing into you
doesn't automatically transform you into
a being who will always be just in every
circumstance you have to work at it and
so our virtues are requiring us to
continually exercise them against vices
that threaten us from within
finally he talks very briefly about
courage or fortitude and he says that
you know what if what do we have to say
about this well says it's the plainest
proof of the ills of this life because
it's those ills those evil things that
were compelled to endure patiently and
you might say well that doesn't sound
like courage to me but this is one way
in which courage or fortitude is
understood enduring the
things that we find scary that we find
painful and doing what we need to do
despite that all of these virtues are
supposed to work together all of them
are things that were supposed to
cultivate all of them are you know steps
you might say on the path towards the
divine but none of them for Augustine
are the supreme good they are just
something that helps us towards the
supreme good or you might say that the
supreme good wants us to have so that we
can enjoy the supreme good and this is
the argument that he provides here in
book 19 taking us in some respect beyond
the perspectives of ancient philosophy
into Christian theology
you